have you heard of tensions you may know
them for some of their most popular
games like pub G but did you know that
they are not only the most valuable
gaming parent in the world but also one
of largest companies in the world with a
market cap of 449 billion dollars they
absolutely dwarf their competitors with
the second largest being Nintendo at 43
billion dollar market cap they learn
everything from league of legends to
supercell to fortnight the FIFA online
to Miniclip and that's not even
scratching the surface and wait did I
mentioned that they were only
established 20 years ago
so how detention gets so big so fast and
get involved in everything from
investing to payment systems make sure
stick around till end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saudis so all-star in
November of 1998 when Pony ma Huaqing
and for his friends established tension
Inc in a Cayman Islands it originally
started off as a social media company
that offered a free PC based instant
messaging service called o IC Q but they
would eventually have to change your
name to QQ due to a lawsuit from ICQ of
AOL they were able to secure 1 million
users in just their first year but they
wouldn't be profitable until 2001 this
was following the release of mobile QQ
which is a messaging platform for mobile
phones and in 2001 tension turned over
their very first profit of a nice 1.2
million dollars
the South African media company Naspers
saw a lot of potential and tension right
off the bat and bought 46.5% of the
company in 2001 it was then list on a
Hong Kong Stock Exchange On June 16 2004
but I had a pre disappointing IPO as
this is right after a dot-com bubble and
investors were pretty leery of investing
in the company at first they mainly made
money from advertising in premium users
of QQ but by 2005 they were charging for
QQ Mobile which is a value-added
cellular service and there are also
licensing off their penguin logo ask for
attention games this was founded in 2003
with the focus on online games their
first game with QQ ting which was
followed by dungeon fighter online queue
of fantasy and sungeun this was their
first step into social media and gave me
space and with that they were off their
first challenge was Microsoft and their
MSN Messenger in 2005 the market
penetration of MSN Messenger was not
even close to QQ but Allison did have
50% of the business people feeling the
pressure from this tension will reject
Microsoft's offer to join the two
channels and instead they were announced
the launch of a new QQ QQ 2005 and after
that MSN was really never able to
penetrate the Chinese market due to huge
government limitations these
restrictions really made it impossible
for international corporations to really
keep up and at the same time
QQ really wasn't able to come out of the
China so I'm not really sure who won
here it was really stalemate and both of
them lost out on an opportunity to
expand it internationally so clearly
international competitors really
couldn't compete with tension inside
China and as a result the next step of
business was to eliminate domestic
competition the biggest domestic
competitor for social networking was
company 51 comm they really saw how
successful QQ was and wanted some of the
pie at this time people have to go to
internet cafes to use a computer in most
cases and as a result whoever is the
most popular service with an internet
cafes what are in the market the do
countries really battled out the 100,000
internet cafes are located in China and
they were neck-and-neck until the end of
2007 but critical strategic errors are
rushed to go public and internal
conflicts would take down company 51 and
in 2009 tension would come out on top as
a social networking King if you guys
have ever heard about the vastly popular
app reach' in China these are the people
who are behind it they came out with
regen 2011 and it was a one-stop shop
for everything you could chat played
games paid bills shop and even access
government services this is pretty much
a must have app in China and as a result
in just a very first year after its
release they were able to garner 100
million users and by 2016 they had 800
and million active users and now they
have over 1 billion active users but
again they really haven't been able to
break out of China with their social
media networks as 90% of their users are
in China their biggest competition
outside of China is obviously Facebook
and it has been an up-and-down battle
you think that Facebook has been ahead
for a pretty long time and intention
comes out and over and takes over and
then you're sure analysts say attention
slate is widening but it's really just a
back and forth battle and still there is
really no clear winner but this is a
tension was able to become a significant
player in the social media market as I
said before they had popular games is
pretty much every single John Rowe from
QQ team QQ dancer QQ speed and QQ
fantasy but it's not until after 2010
that they would become a gaming giant
and they would pretty much acquire
themselves all the way up there
here are some of tensions most notable
acquisitions over the past 10 years they
have an 80 percent stake in grinding
Gear games of Patti Beck's am 100
percent stake in right game of stone
heart and league of legends undisclosed
majority stake in Miniclip which is a
huge gaming website for in percent stake
in epic games of fortnight infinity
blade and gears war 5% staking
Activision Blizzard of Call of Duty and
Skylanders 5% and Ubisoft of Assassin's
Creed watchdogs far cry and Just Dance
5% and Paradox Interactive of Crusader
Kings and hearts of iron and eighty four
point three percent stake and super
south of of course
clash of clans clash Royale and brawl
stars and those are just a major
holdings
they have so many smaller investments as
well like FIFA online 3 Need for Speed
and pub Jean they basically took all the
money they made from the social media
platforms and poured into gaming
companies and on top of this they
started developing their own gaming
products as well in 2016 it launched a
gaming platform that was dug tgp or
tension gaming platform but it was
officially named blade it was an Intel
powered console running Windows 10 it
mainly ran ported version of attention
games which is already a lot but they're
also trying to get
party support and in April of 2017 they
showcased their flagship gaming platform
we game this would host games and
content services from all over the world
it was basically steam paula larger with
200 million users and opposed to steamed
125 million users so in the end tension
basically bought their way up in the
gaming industry and this time launching
their own products and if not just games
that they were looking at takeover they
were looking to take over the whole
entertainment industry in April of 2009
they lost itq June which is a smart
interactive television service in
conjunction with TCL and the 2015 they
launched tension pictures which is a
film company that produced and
distributed films they also had tension
penguin pictures which is a production
unit that really focused on online
dramas and select feature films now that
they had a pretty good entry into movie
market it was time to go for comics on
March 21st 2012 tension with lunch
tension comic which would soon become
China's largest animation platform and
then in September of 2017
they announced that they had plans to
introduce Chinese online comics to every
market in the entire world their first
target was North America they started
working with a San Francisco based
digital publisher named tapas media and
then in 2014
tension will enter the music industry
they were able to form exclusive in
China music deals with Sony
Water Music Group and YG Entertainment
and in 2017 they sign a deal with
Universal Music Group to stream music in
China they also entered a partnership
with Alibaba Group for music streaming
rights in December of 2017 and tension
Music Entertainment and Spotify agreed
to swap 10% of each of their stock and
with that they were able to take over
social media
gaming and music industry next was
ecommerce and payments in September of
2005 tension would launch Pepe calm and
tenpai this is an online payment system
that's very similar to PayPal and can
support b2b b2c and c2c payments as for
the e-commerce space their biggest
competitors obviously the Alibaba Group
tension to enter this market by buying a
50% stake in the Chinese e-commerce
upside JD calm and in a May of 2014
JD became the first Chinese e-commerce
website to be listed on NASDAQ
but unfortunately PayPal calm wasn't
doing it too well and it wasn't able to
handle fake goods very well and then
they would eventually fully shut down on
April 1st 2016 this was clearly a
planned April Fool's prank
not really but JD would relaunch paint
be calm pretty soon after so it really
should have been and as of 2017 was acts
reported that ten she was working with
China's central bank apparently they're
developing a central payments clearing
platform for online payments but that's
not it they had more ventures in the
internet space as well they even had
their own search engine this search
engine was called social calm and was
released in March of 2006 and by October
of 2012 this would be the 33rd most
visited website in the entire world and
in 2008 they were launched her own media
player called QQ player and in their own
browser called trident they would also
have their own micro blogging service
and video streaming website as it was
evident they pretty much dominated
everything they put their hands on but
recently they have actually been in a
transition phase recently I've actually
been transforming into more of a holding
company investment firm they launched a
Wii Bank in January of 2015 and that was
Thames first online only Bank and 2016
they partner with Foxconn and luxury car
manufacturer harmony New Energy Auto to
found future mobility which is a car
start that is supposed to solve fully
autonomous electric vehicles by 2020 and
in 2017 I bought a 5% stake in Tesla and
in November of 2017
they bark whoppers in steak and snap Inc
and now they're teaming up with the LEGO
Group to make online games they even
have their own credit score tension
pretty much owns everything so it's no
wonder that they are one of the large
companies in the entire world in May of
they surpassed Wells Fargo to become one
of the top 10 most valuable companies in
the entire world they also became the
first Asian company to surpass the 500
billion dollar mark and then soon after
they surpassed Facebook and became one
of the top five biggest firms in the
world in 2018 however they were honest
like decline as some of their
investments slid and they were under
heavy government scrutiny for the gaming
business in fact in August of 2018 they
lost 50 billion dollars in valuation in
just a single week but since then they
have recovered and they are once again
on the rise and after this rate soon
enough they will become the largest
company in the world outside of China if
you have heard about tension it's
probably because after gave me
acquisitions but they actually started
off as a social media giant and since
then they have gone to hold large
portions of the gaming entertainment
ecommerce and payments industries they
started off as a Facebook of China but
then we're able to grow into pretty much
every single industry this is mainly
because of the unique restrictions in
China that make it very hard for new
businesses and international competitors
they have really uses opportunity and
very wisely and I've been able to go
into a huge global conglomerate they are
today and right now they're actually in
a transition phase they're moving away
from being a social media and gaming
company that also has other ventures
into a huge holding company an
investment firm that also has their own
side quests and that is a truly amazing
story of tension but that's all I have
for you guys intentioned make sure
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys liked this video make sure of a
like and consider subscribing you can
see more videos just like this one all
attention will by America and China will
take over the world but till then I'm
Marie I'll see you guys on the next one